just like the haunting of hill house
blimey is stuffed with creepy secret
ghosts watching events from the shadows
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'll be revealing all the hidden
ghosts i found in blind manor where to
find them
and explaining their connection to the
lady of the lake and flora's dollhouse
spoilers ahead of course so take care in
the first episode just after dany
arrives as flora shows her around the
house and they go up the stairs
you can spot a figure worrying a hat
lurking in the corner
this is the plague doctor ghost and you
can see him move his head ever so
slightly upwards as if observing
dany's arrival the plague doctors
introduced in the eighth episode when he
comes to the manor to diagnose viola's
sickness
he's killed around a decade after her
death when he accidentally wanders into
the path of the vengeful lady of the
lake while the manor is being used as a
quarantine location
after a plague outbreak in blind you can
see him next
reflected in the mirror of dany's room
after miles wanders
in and when dany is having dinner for
the first time with mrs gross and the
children
you can see the plague doctor's beaked
mask brown coat and gloves just behind
miles and in front of the dining room
door
he seems to quickly disappear once the
camera moves to a wider shot
later after flora's finished her bath
she opens the door to her room and you
can see the silhouette of the creepy
ghost
then after dany tucks miles into bed the
doctor reappears inside the bathroom
and when dany walks through the bathroom
you can see his reflection in the mirror
as dany puts flora to bed the plague
doctor can be seen hiding near the
window in her bedroom
later that night you can spot his
beak-shaped mask and this shot here as
he silently watches dany coming out of
the kitchen
and then he's here at the end of the
corridor the next day
after miles shows dany the spider he
appears at the end of the garden
then as dany and the kids go back to the
house he's lurking outside the manor in
this shot
at the same time that peter quint's
ghost first appears to dany
at lunch the plague doctor appears
almost in plain sight in the kitchen
fireplace
the next time dany puts flora to bed the
plague doctor's watching on yet again
this time from the corridor and when
miles comes to ask
dany for a fan he's back to lurking in
the bathroom
this next appearance is very slight but
you can just spot his hat reflected in
the walking closet mirror here
he also later watches dany emerge from
flora's room
after she was locked in the closet by
the children and then at the very end of
the first episode the creepy profile of
the ghost appears in the garden
there's a spooky moment in the second
episode when dany descends into the
basement to recover flora's lady of the
lake doll
as she turns off the light and leaves
hidden in the pile of discarded old
dolls you can spot the doll face ghost
sitting up this ghost is a little boy
that flora discovered playing with her
dollhouse
he gets his name doll face ghost from
the mask that flora took from another
doll in the attic and put on him
as she said his face was unfinished the
boy became a ghost when he was killed by
the lady of the lake during one of her
walks to her daughter's old room
you can spot his ghost standing at the
end of a corridor on the ground floor
while dany is looking for miles in the
second episode
in the third episode you can just make
out his nightgown here outside the door
as the police officer goes to leave and
then moments later he's back in the
house just behind danny
the next morning as dany's getting up
you can spot him lurking in the shadows
and in a super creepy moment he appears
in the mirror of flora's bedroom where
he turns his head as dany walks past
and you can see him move his head again
as he watches dany leave flora's room
after she kisses her good night in the
fourth episode
you can also see him crouched in the
corner of the kitchen here
which must be one of his favorite hiding
spots because he's back there in the
fifth episode
and during one of mrs gross's time loops
the little boy ghost pops up behind some
furniture in the main hallway
also hidden in this shot to the right of
the staircase is the ghost of the vicar
somebody looking on the vicar was the
second victim who accidentally found
himself caught in the lady of the lake's
deadly path and he appears again in the
fifth episode in the bathroom between
flora and miles's bedrooms
in the third episode as the police
officer is leaving you can spot a hidden
ghost
standing to attention at the back of the
entrance hall we don't know exactly how
this soldier died but during one of
flora's memories while she was tucked
away
her uncle henry tells her about a ghost
he once knew at bly manor
i had a friend when i was your age too
in this house in fact he was a soldier
and i was very afraid of him until i
gave him a story
we don't know if viola's ghost killed
this soldier or if he died of some other
cause however during the second world
war the british government requisitioned
large country houses and estates to
serve as part of the war effort
and it's quite possible that this
soldier was someone working at blind
manor at the time who was unlucky enough
to cross paths with the lady of the lake
he also appears behind miss jaisal as
she plays with flora's dolls
a nice detail in this scene is that the
camera very briefly
sharpens its focus on the soldier doll
just before he shows up behind rebecca
this next one's tricky to see but you
can spot the soldier for just
a split second when the lightning
flashes in the kitchen while rebecca and
peter are talking together the soldier
ghost
also appears again towards the end of a
corridor just after the doctor who's
come to check on flora leaves
you'll need to watch this scene
carefully because when the doctor was
talking to dany the corridor was empty
but after he leaves the ghost is now
there
and in the fourth episode he's creepily
watching dany outside while she burns
her former fiancee spectacles in the
bonfire
then in the sixth episode as dany chases
flora up the stairs into the attic you
can spot both the soldier ghost and the
vicar ghost
looking on the eighth episode reveals
the dark backstory of viola and perdata
and midway through
just before perdata goes to ask arthur
to open the trunk as she descends the
stairs the portrait of her dead sister
seems to come alive and there's a little
angry sound in the air
some other creepy apparitions that are
harder to identify
include these hands grabbing onto a
chair while mrs gross and owen are
eating in the kitchen
meaning there's a ghost hiding under the
table and judging by the sleeves it's
probably the doll face
ghost there's an unknown ghost at the
back of the entrance hall in the fourth
episode wearing what looks like britches
and knee-high socks
and that same figure appears in the
doorway of the chapel when the winged
graves arrive home in the fifth episode
and there seems to be a ghost lurking at
the back of this corridor which looks
like it might be the doll face ghost but
it's a little too blurry to be sure
though the hidden figure definitely
wasn't there earlier on the same day
there's also a ghostly figure just
behind jaime while she and dany are out
looking for peter quint
and its long light-coloured robe
suggests it could be the dollface ghost
again
and there are even more plague doctor
ghost appearances to look out for
on top of the ones i mentioned earlier
when dany bends down to pick up flora's
faceless doll
as she gets up there's a blurry figure
reflected in the mirror that wasn't
there before
judging from the brownish colors it
looks like the plague doctor again
in the second episode the mask doctor
can be seen spying on mrs gross and
jamie over here
and as jaime comes back in the house
he's right at the end of the corridor
during the game of hide and seek in the
second episode you can spot the doctor
lurking near a window in a room where
dany goes to look for the children
and during the game the ghost of miss
jaisal is watching in the background
while dany's back is turned
in the third episode while dany mrs
gross miles and flora are talking to the
police officer who's come to investigate
dany's sighting of peter quint in the
background you can spot the outline of
the plague doctor's distinctive beaky
mask as he observes the scene
and in the fourth episode you can spot
the creepy hat and beak
crouching by the desk in the study as
dany walks past with a bottle of wine
and there are even a few secret ghosts
when characters aren't at bly manor
it's not immediately obvious but the
backpacker that comes out of the room
dany's staying in at the hostel in
london
is very likely another hidden ghost
notice that dany's room is for two
people but
only one bed is made up and it's
unlikely anyone
else has been staying there as she's
been using the sheets from the second
bed to cover up the mirrors in the room
another ghost outside the manny you
might have missed is the ghost of edmond
who appears very briefly in the wind of
a taxi that rushes past dany in the
first episode
i also have a theory that there could be
some ghosts haunting miles's boarding
school
these two priests in the headmaster's
office while miles is being reprimanded
seems strangely silent throughout and
not
really necessary for the scene and when
the camera cuts to a different angle the
priest to the front of the desk seems to
no longer be there
likewise when miles goes to the school's
chapel to read a passage from the bible
there's a mysterious man painting the
wall
he seems like an unnecessary character
to add to this scene given miles has no
interaction with him
and i suspect he may be a ghost as well
similar to the clock fixing ghost in
hill house
like dany's backpacker ghost these
figures may simply be there to add to
the oppressive sense that miles already
feels from the ghost of peter quint
an interesting detail is that all the
hidden blind mana ghosts we need to look
out for throughout the season
appear as dolls when flora introduces
dany to her doll house in the very first
episode
notice that rebecca jassel's doll is
behind flora's bed which is fitting as
the ghost of the dead au pair has been
taking possession of flora
similarly peter quint's doll is hiding
behind the wardrobe in miles's bedroom
the plague doctor is in the bathroom
exactly where he appears as dany is
walking through the room
the doll-faced ghost is down in the
entrance hall where he appeared in the
fifth episode
as is the soldier ghost who appeared
there in episode three
perdata is in the attic which is where
she was killed after opening viola's
trunk of clothes and jewels and she's
the ghost who flora tells to be quiet in
the second episode
i haven't seen the dead vicar in the
dining room as he is here but presumably
he's lurking around there in a scene
somewhere
and mrs gross is a doll with the red top
and the green skirt
sneakily this doll is an early clue to
the fact that mrs gross is already dead
and is actually a ghost at this point
something that isn't revealed until the
fifth episode
the other three dolls of the characters
that are still alive
flora miles and dany as we later find
out though flora and miles have already
been possessed by ghosts and dany will
eventually become possessed as well by
the lady of the lake
now if you're as creeped out as me by
blind man as hidden ghosts spying on the
home's inhabitants
you'll find it troubling to know
especially if you're online at home more
than ever that your own
internet service provider is also
logging all of your online activity
one way to block these secret spies is
to use a virtual private network
whenever you're connected to the
internet
a vpn helps protect your privacy by
encrypting your internet connection and
making your data unreadable to
others preventing your isp government
agencies or malicious hackers from
reading your emails
private messages or knowing which
websites you're visiting which is why i
want to thank the sponsor of this video
nordvpn who offers one of the world's
best virtual
private networks one thing we especially
like about nord is the super fast
download speeds on its 5 000 plus
servers through the use of new
generation vpn technologies like wire
guard
and unlike many free and slower vpns
nord has a no
log policy meaning it doesn't record or
retain details of your online activity
when you're connected to its service
plus if you're a video junkie nordvpn
can help you bypass jio restrictions or
censorship on content not available to
view in your country
just pick a server in another location
and browse the internet as if you were
there
you can connect up to six devices at the
same time including your laptop
tablet desktop phone and home router so
you can cover all of your connected
devices
for a limited time nordvpn are offering
all our viewers 68
of the two-year plan and a bonus month
completely free
just visit nordvpn.comflix or tap the
link in the video description to access
the offer
that's nordvpn.comflix for a huge
68 discount and an additional month
completely free
and to discover even more things you
missed in the haunting of blind manor
and easter eggs which connect it to the
haunting of hill house
tap here to watch my upcoming video on
that or follow the link in the video
description i'll add the links here as
soon as the video is ready
so did you spot any other hidden ghosts
this season
and what were your favorite details in
the show leave your comments below
and if you enjoyed this then a thumbs up
is hugely appreciated
next tap left for a full breakdown of
the ending of blind manor and what that
final shot with jaime really means
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like thanks for watching and see
you next time yippie guy movie lovers